had a lot of words for russell  brussbrook care to share any of them  i mean me and him going back and forth  since uh okc that's my guy that's my big  brother  uh he's been taking care of me you know  since i got to okc  and when we on the court you know we're  just competing so um end of the day he  had words for me i have words for him  the end of the day uh  when the game ends we  had a lot of words for russell  brestbrook care to share any of them  i mean me and him going back and forth  since okc that's my guy that's my big  brother  he's been taking care of me you know  since i got to okc  and when we on the court you know we're  just competing so um end of the day he  had worked for me i have words for him  the end of the day  when the game ends we